hey I was going bros my name is fran fat
today I am very very very excited
because I get to play in South Park the
fractured but whole but not just South
Park the fractured Baca whole I also
have a surprise I get to wear this the
nozzle is ripped oh oh it still smells
this is like the oculus rift but for
your nose its smellivision obviously
this game is all about the farts I want
to be immersed in the farts now I can
smell the farts in the game what a great
idea I look insane already this is so
weird I wish you could feel I'm told
that this was developed by French people
of course only French people would
develop something weird like this
[ __ ] weirdos okay but without further
ado let's say smell some [ __ ] here we go
beautiful okay so I'm told if I press X
I'll fart in the game and then I'll
smell the fart let's just for the sake
of it give it a go oh oh that's bad Oh
give me a hit me up again oh oh [ __ ] me
haha it's the dumbest thing ever but I
love it it really smells like [ __ ] it
genuinely smelled like a tiny little
fart I can feel the air coming out as
well it feels like someone's butthole is
just really close and someone try to
sneak a fart it's very silent very soft
like a mother's touch okay why do I keep
doing this to myself oh did you get
locked out I'm afraid little Eric put a
lock on the door to keep me out I'm sure
he has the passcode written down here
somewhere
hey hustles what if I fart in front of
her mommy you wet one oh that was a wet
one okay we have to find the passcode
got it got it where is the passcode
that's then okay we need the code we got
to find a passcode let's go upstairs and
see
we can find I'm told that if we're
getting later on there's gonna be some
[ __ ] happening learn literally yes I
gotta say like the first softcore game
was so good I'm so excited for this new
one
keep looking at on Cartman's journal
right hey hey it's that Cartman more
fanfiction oh wow
beware do not open Kuno Lee key code
[ __ ] your mom oh [ __ ] me that the smell
is just disgusting
but I feel so immersed in the gameplay
right now guys I really feel like I'm
truly in the South Park universe thanks
to smellivision
so I think we should go to the toilet
cuz I know they're surprised waiting for
us there here we go
we can take a [ __ ] are you guys ready
for this oh boy I'm about to die from
I'm about to get gassed to death to
death throes let's take a [ __ ]
here we go I'm charging it with the
triggers yeah comma and then I have to
spread my ass cheeks with the thumbs
that a smelly [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh god
dammit miss click G said [ __ ] French
people god damnit understand that now
I'm getting into this fart smells I kind
of like it
how about that French people you're not
so bad after all ah [ __ ] haha balls
balls balls you clunk you I'm 12 yes yes
I am 12 okay it's [ __ ] you mom
oh hey we're dad enough mosquito we have
to act fast before the freedom house can
if there is someone in this town who
knows someone who works at Netflix and
we have to find that person today but we
were gonna start our franchise playing
with movies the super Craig Netflix
series comes later we can start with the
Netflix series you know that's what
freedom pals are thinking but who in
this town could have a connection to
Netflix it could be anybody that is what
we must find out Fast Pass mosquito
you're on AVL's on all known freedom
pals activity human chitin Fastpass see
what you can learn about their Pio is
super Craig just I don't know browse the
internet or something let's go Vince
okay alright let's talk to you guys at
galaxy Cube is a super powerful artifact
from space so don't touch it yeah well
you take that outside dude take that up
oh [ __ ] oh oh I think we have an
ordinary citizen snooping around it's
got a really beefy smell you know I kind
of liked it and counted into it it's
weird
I never let this ordinary citizen into
the key layer listen bro we are all
superheroes and you aren't so you can't
hang out with that please do us all the
solid and [ __ ] up okay well that's a
little harsh have you smelled my [ __ ]
well he doesn't say anything
top bad guys for face okay yes hahaha
all right I can say not bad okay what
about here that's mysterious eat okay
what about here they're either stupid ah
here then great all right in order to
play superheroes you have to have a
superhero persona all right can fill out
your character sheet on Kunta Graham do
you have a 60 gram page I do have a
courser grant page yeah boy you're not
even on kingster grandad
well I guess I can create one for you so
the first thing we need to fill out on
your character sheet oh cool I can make
my cash yeah what kind of superhero are
you ah
that's all son I gotta be the punk music
beat stir oh yeah it's like a flash or
Quicksilver I like it okay but now we
need to find out what terrible thing in
your past drives you you see douche all
superheroes have a compelling backstory
let's check from that backstory that
their powers gain meaning let's take you
back to when you were just a child
you lay awake that night like so many
other nights you couldn't sleep because
you knew you weren't like the other kids
you walked to the mirror oh cool I get
to play it
alright there's still fart yes I can
goddamnit it really feels like someone's
[ __ ] is constantly in front of my
[ __ ] face I walk to the mirror you
looked in the mirror and you felt alone
and that's when it happened a loud noise
you swore you could hear your mother
calling for help oh come on
you left your room my mom I must save
her out in the hallway you saw two
intruders in front of your parents door
you had to stop them from hurting your
parents you knew you had the power to
stop them so for the first time you
called upon your speech to power oh [ __ ]
I get to find him okay as a super fast
speedster hero
you bent space-time oh cool just spring
into action with super speed you know
I'm gonna for it on that one time punch
okay I need to do here hundreds of our
corner fix things to punch a distant guy
closest to you you moved in and punched
him okay I'll do that just never got
cool once his atoms returned to their
original positions the intruder
realigned when he was up against damn we
weren't expecting a super hero to live
here this early the intruder struck our
hero man take this huh
geez says there's nothing they could do
I guess they hear his final strike a
supersonic dash
okay and I'll check both this is cool I
like how they improve their just truly
calm baby
shooter soundly defeated you thought you
were safe until a third massive intruder
into the fray bigger than the other two
intruders can beg yeah oh sure this is
the big pool I just flushed one little
[ __ ] now here's one more before you
could react these swung is gargantuan
fish in your small body doing critical
damage oh yeah
oh Jesus Christ hitting the [ __ ] out
okay okay ultimate ability here we go
Jason
that's a lot of breath
nice and so you beat them all seem to be
okay but then you finally reach don't go
in there yeah when you open that door
changed your life forever and led you to
fighting crime haha
you were too late because when you open
that door you saw you saw your dead [ __ ]
you man hahahaha
ain't nothing words yeah that's a pretty
heavy bag you fight crime because you
never forgot the night you weren't in
time and you saw your own father the man
you trusted [ __ ] you man it's like a
ripple in time you can't ever change
isn't it yeah
alright now you need to go out into the
town and do superhero stuff you know
help people and fight crime and dump
[ __ ] like that there's some starting
costumes in the wardrobe and remember if
you ever want to try out a different
class just come talk to me that's cool
okay we got our we got a class in a
rigid story I feel more invested in the
in the story right now in my characters
develop made okay let's head out hey
we're looking cool oh we can set a stop
from so sick of the [ __ ] smells I
[ __ ] feel disgusting
[Music]
what is this what's happening where are
we going oh oh no no oh man that's
disgusting
thank you call his human kind plant
protecta not again we all know what's
happening here we were supposed to be a
duo remember tweek yeah I remember
so when I walked out of goona fridge you
should've walked out with me I like
coded bread because you had your own
booby thank god you're here they're
really going at it
super Craig had to have Louise before
wonder twinkles introduced and they no
sense otherwise y'all don't make no
sense because you're a traitor tweek and
now you're with a group of super
traitors this was started by you by
people who thought there should be
preferential treatment to certain heroes
we are the ones who walked out of the
[ __ ] franchise mysterion Eric you
must listen to me right now I'm speaking
to you tell us I had any franchises
going nowhere uh it's the truth Eric you
guys are kind of douchebags
he just called us douchebags in my mind
he did all right you son of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] could read deal with you
dad gone okay we get to fight now cool
we're pals as long as there's no farting
I'm alright new kick don't let Carmen
fool you it's cool I like how you can
move around while playing hey wake up
you out
now you'll calm down GABA get me dick I
do more than that to get through my
summer shooting car car stay out of the
snake damn [ __ ] [ __ ] you dude Dilawar
yeah we're clear that's good here we go
that's a good question what are the
teams I don't [ __ ] know all right
here we go let's beat the [ __ ] out shake
it off shake it out
nice and Taylor Swiffer and they snuck
in there I appreciate that I look really
like that almost as bad as smelling
these forums but damn you kid you're
really getting the hang of this biggie
wait what about Co oh [ __ ] come on
please not [ __ ] literally what happened
to the clean timmy got away hey hey
completely made to my mind you okay no
seriously you guys yeah you [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of my brains huh I grabbed him
we fought for a little bit but it's his
mental powers are too strong so we did
all that for nothing
not quite I got to me cell phone hey
there's sure to be a lead on that let's
get this back to base super quick and
analyze it
hey we did add that was a demo why did
we choose this life right the German
that's what I want to know we dedicate
our lives to fighting crime for one
reason to make a billion dollars on a
superhero franchise now let's go through
the plan one more time
first we start with a [ __ ] movie then we
do the super Craig movie then super
Craig and kun will join forces in the
human kite movie just feel like I should
wear like this thank you how come I have
to have a Netflix series I want to movie
- you have a movie mysterion you're in
the third [ __ ] and friends united movie
after your Netflix series yeah but he
think he doesn't ever get his own movie
do I get my own movie not everyone gets
their own movie but free choice we in
fact we want to make billions of dollars
and I think we should start with a
tupperware movie right start with a
black superhero Marvel is banking a
black superhero movie yet now maybe we
did gear to get to that we follow their
plan we do all the real people first and
we sneak the black guy in a phase-three
how about we just do movie starring all
of us like all the time but then we're
just rehashing the same old material
there's nothing wrong with doing the
exact same movie to start a franchise
okay JJ Abrams ok ok so you're on
Carmen's side he just likes this plan
because he gets two movies face one yeah
we have to just go with this plan we
don't even have one movie yet how did it
get to this
how did we Crump so far apart you go
with the plan maybe we'll just go and do
our own franchise yeah yeah oh you want
super worries how would you watch
yeah dude Civil War [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
get on the house
we'll make way more money on our
franchise go ahead bet you get okay now
this story makes sense they're making
fun of all the super Murray movie
franchises and how they milk that [ __ ]
to [ __ ] death I thought Civil War
what's it supposed to happen to kill
phase three stop [ __ ] dialects Tucker
lid very sure man much better title much
better
SARP I'm gonna have to do this but you
leave me no choice
Hey oh man last season of the cyborg was
so good as well I can't wait to see all
the references from that coming into
this game alright so that was it that
was time for party the fractured but
whole the demo at least I can't wait for
the full version I'm so excited
live like for you are as well I'll see
you bros in that one and smell smell you
later alright stay awesome bris
[Music]
you